for a superhero who runs so fast that he
can vibrate through time the flash sure
hasn't had a quick trip to the multiplex
fans have been waiting for a solo movie
starring ezra miller's incarnation of
scarlet speedster barry allen since we
last saw him on the big screen in 2017's
theatrical cut of justice league
since then a rotating creative team and
shifting priorities at dc entertainment
have repeatedly pushed the flash's turn
in the spotlight further into the future
the biggest glimmer of hope for eager
flash fanatics came from the aero vs
crisis on infinite earth's event on the
cw in january 2020
during which miller briefly met tv flash
grant gustin in a delightful moment of
multiverse collision
about barry allen no what does that mean
how can this should be impossible now to
be impossible now
now we're finally getting some real news
about the solo flash movie and it seems
that crossover cameo may have been far
more than just fan service
during the dc fandom virtual event
miller joined director andy muschetti
producer barbara muschetti and
screenwriter christina hodgson to
deliver some bite-sized flashbacks
teasing the movie's potential to open up
the dc multiverse and tie every existing
depiction of dc's many worlds into one
continuity
since a flash has yet to go before
cameras the team had to get a little
creative in hyping the project which
motivated them to show off a sneak peek
at the flash's flashy new suit
i like your outfit it seems sick and
comfy yours is pretty cool
it seems safe breathable
muscadi and company debuted the flash's
new suit via some pretty impressive
concept art undoubtedly a departure from
the clunkier armor the characters
sported in justice league
as you can see it's more organic you can
see
light embedded in it it has been built
by his friend bruce wayne this time
that brings us back to the flash's
multiverse angle as both ben affleck and
michael keaton are confirmed to be
reprising the roles as batman for the
film
obviously barry's friend would be
affleck's bruce wayne as the two fought
side by side in justice league
but it's interesting to note that one of
the concept illustrations shown during
the discussion features a silhouette far
more reminiscent of keaton's 1989 bat
suit than affleck's more recent stubby
eared cape and cowl
we'll have to wait and see just what
kind of relationship the flash has with
each of these dueling batman and how his
new suit plays into their universe
busting bond
like many movies ones of the superhero
variety especially the flash has gone
through many
changes over the years since its
existence was first made known
a little over seven years ago in july
2013 the hollywood reporter noted that
warner brothers and dc entertainment had
put in motion plans for a standalone
flash movie
at the time intended to be released in
2016.
greg berlanti producer extraordinaire
who has been instrumental in bringing to
life the flash series of the aeroverse
was confirmed to be developing the flash
flick
by october 2014 warner brothers slid the
flash in place for a 2018 release
the same year that jason momoa's aquaman
solo pick wound up diving into cinemas
things were chugging along quite nicely
our first draft script got going then
phil lord and christopher miller the
guys who co-produced the oscar-winning
spider-man into the spider-verse were
working on a story treatment
but the project's wheels started to get
stuck when a revolving door of directors
passed through and a handful of
different writers fiddled with the
script
eventually andy muschetti who scored
major points with fans for his two-part
adaptation of stephen king's
it and bumblebee's christina hudson
stepped in as director and writer
respectively
now the flash is finally on track and
it'll be here soon
ish starring ezra miller in the lead
role in both ben affleck and michael
keaton playing different dimension
version to batman the movie is scheduled
to race into theaters on june 2nd
2022 probably check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about dc
films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one